oui j'ai connu hier on a fait notre
premier film ensemble 40 ans tenir
c'étaient les gaietés de l'escadre non
pas du tout c'était un film qui
s'appelait papa est bègue a été mis en
scène par irina avec jeanne manette
après nous avons fait les guettait
l'escadron
[Applaudissements]
au début du parlant
non on s'est connus lisait son tour de
chant concert mayol vous avez connu
pendant le film sans fil a débuté dans
le chinois aussi saluer être son
deuxième film je crois et puis moi ou
situe juste au dessus
des souvenirs
aux îles en premier film
comme il l'avait un peu ce côté chevalin
j'me rappelle cette époque là y avait
une très grande jument ton qui
s'appelait uranie et je la plaie sûrs à
nîmes et lui
m'appelait parce qu'à ce moment là
j'étais blond j'avais les cils et les
sourcils très blonds naples est albinos
albinos là on s'appelait albinos et moi
je la paie uranie
glamour fallait souvenirs on en a des
tonnes
et des tonnes et 1 qui m'échappe air
jeudi pour moi en dehors du comédien ccc
c'est l'homme qui est parti l'homme
laissé une période où on a pas
jamais plus rencontrer jusqu'aux jo nous
enfin notre société on a tourné ce film
qui s'appelait
la jalle ravisseurs
cette voyons voyons très souvent
je pense d'ailleurs que dans une telle
circonstance il ya pas grand chose à
dire que les mots sont inutiles pour moi
en dehors du comédien qu'ils étaient ses
pensées c'est l'homme est parti
l'homme s'était alors
elle très grande droiture et les très
grands loyauté
voilà
et sous des dehors comme ça un peu
soulaya légende
celle sur laquelle on peut conclure vous
est contée sternum droit comme une barre
est si rare
très rare
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]